there is nothing as obnoxious as some
jerk laying on their horn in traffic
although it's something that we all love
to hate
the horn does in fact have a purpose
because before
it was madness
[Music]
in the early days of the automobile the
roads were a riot of sound drivers could
use whistles sirens and belts to alert
pedestrians and other cars what they
were up to
if you were driving in london every car
had to have a guy with a red flag walk
in front of it imagine being that guy
miller rhys hutchinson was an inventor
who lived in new york city
disturbed by the increasing number of
accidents he sat down and invented the
klaxon which was a horn with a sound so
unique and distinct
it became the preferred choice for cars
and their drivers
the invention delighted the people of
the uk so much a car race called the
emancipation run was created to
celebrate getting rid of that flag guy
and replacing him with a horn
it runs to this day
miller reese hutchison went on to do
many great things he worked for thomas
edison he also invented the first
practical version of the hearing aid but
the car horn is perhaps his most iconic
creation
love them or hate them
it changed the acoustic landscape of the
world
and gave you a way to give that guy who
just cut you off a piece of your mind
[Music]
you